[Music]
chemically by rescuers and emergency
service here in the UK I'm the project
manager for the step development here in
Cambridge Bayern risky step stands for
service transformation in efficiency
program the efficiency program really is
all about trying to make edition C's in
the back office trying to save money so
that we can redirect those funds to the
sharp end to the firefighters the
operational crews
[Music]
we had to find ways of becoming more
cost-effective and cheaper without
sacrificing operational integrity as a
BPM developer I am responsible for
implementing business process solutions
using IBM BPM one concept of x-axis is a
smarter process
so not just process improvement by
replacing a spreadsheet for a form but
by automating assessment processes our
business analysts go out and together
with the process owners and stakeholders
they determine or they determine the the
add leads process how we do things now
they model that in IBM blueworks live
and then together with the development
team and myself we translate that into
something that you can then and develop
and begin on / y-bn bpm we're in our
fifth year and we've done 16 into n
processes in BPM and now we've started
to use the demo cloud and typically we
found on those places we say between 60
and 90 percent time-saving efficiencies
so that means literally you know
something that took a week to process or
a process that took a week to perform
now only takes a day or perhaps a matter
of hours BPM on cloud was revelation
Airy really for us the developers has
found the the process of developing
smart approaches on IBM BPM on cloud
much more flexible it kind of allows us
to get to the business process rather
than having to worry about an
administration of a computer system
include something so I think it's fair
to say we're a small team so there's a
lot of work to be done and one of the
biggest pressures is actually
prioritizing and delivering graphically
BPM cloud allows us to do is stop
worrying about the infrastructure allows
us to focus on our business and
delivering better business processes and
that will reflect the powers better
public service we've already got a plan
to move all of our in-house smart
businesses up on
we just feel like the future it's more
flexible it's certainly a lot faster to
develop on but equally and perhaps even
more importantly we can collaborate with
not just the back-office stuff and not
even with just the incident control room
we can do the mobilizing systems around
the mobilizing system is the system that
literally sends the firefighters out to
the incidents
it also has opened up possibilities of
collaboration with other emergency
services you know we we're not in
isolation we have several collaborations
ongoing with with different fire and
rescue services for example but actually
what we can do with those processes is
kind of go out to other Fire Rescue
Service and say look you know look what
we've done look at efficiencies we've
managed there's almost zero startup
costs like the food for doing smart
process on cloud and so you know do you
want to join us if every other Fire
Rescue Service is the same or common
common business process we could make
huge efficiencies across the country so
we've improved our fee for based
processes and that's provided a better
foundation on which to build other
processes and those sorts of processes
could be for example community
prevention community safety that sort of
thing and they are a step towards
operations and operational support so
the thing that excites me most perhaps
about process improvement and the use of
BPM is just how much there is to do and
the way in which by by addressing small
improvements bit by bit you can suddenly
turn around and realize that you've
reach you provides
[Music]